it was an extraordinary pm cues mps
waited some wondered if he'd even show
up but as the prime minister arrived to
a solemn front bench eddie cheers were
very quickly drowned out
[Music]
starmar capitalized and the chamber was
silent as he asked his first question
relaying the details of an alleged
assault by chris pincher
he says
he grabbed my ass
and then he slowly moved his hand down
in front of my groin
i froze
i accept that's not easy listening
but it's a reminder to all those
propping up this prime minister
just how serious the situation is
the pm tried to rally his side focus on
policy but it wasn't working
not least the 500 000 people we got off
welfare into work uh in the last six
months alone mr speaker those are things
that are making differences to the lives
of people up and down the country and
i'm proud of it
no one's cheering
labor unimpressed but look at the pm's
own side their faces said it all
what a pathetic spectacle the the dying
act of his political career is to parrot
that nonsense
and as for those who are left
only in office because no one else is
prepared to debase themselves any longer
the charge of the lightweight brigade
and if we look more closely at what was
going on on the tory benches sachit
javid arrived late to support from
rebels like mark harper but avoiding eye
contact with his old cabinet colleagues
missing from the front bench today was
housing secretary michael gove no word
yet on his position
the mood though was glum
this was pmq's in january jonathan
gullis cheering on the prime minister at
the height of partygate but look at him
today after resigning his junior role in
government last night elsewhere tory
backbenchers used the opportunity to
have their say
does the prime minister think there are
any circumstances in which he should
resign today i ask him to do the
honorable thing
to put the interests of the nation
before his own interest
nothing
left for him to do other than to take
responsibility and resign
the prime minister's response here to
labour's ian lavery perhaps sums up the
tone
hang on in there mr speaker that's what
i'm gonna do
and after pmq's came the scathing
statement from sajid javid who left the
chamber to pats on the back boris
johnson though couldn't have exited much
more quickly labour keen to bid him
farewell
[Music]
kirstama had a good pmqs but it was an
easy day to be leader of the opposition
mps behind the prime minister who
cheered him on through thick and thin
was solemn today the teflon prime
minister losing a grip on his own side